[Music]
guys get ready for the biggest movie of
the year for the biggest franchise of
comic book movie history hit after a hit
and they're gonna end it off strong with
another
massive win in the cinemas that is for
Aquaman 2 we're finally getting a
trailer for it John how excited are you
for the sequel I am submerged in a tank
of excitement oh that's great to hear
Hey koi how excited are you for Lobo I'm
talking to the fishes about it as we
speak with all the Zeal I can muster for
the end of a universe that kind of
exists in continuity sometimes when it's
relevant ladies and gentlemen leave a
like on this video
in all seriousness I'm actually rooting
for this movie so let's see how this
turns out
clever four years ago I was basically
unemployed
water
with no home yeah how bad but now I'm a
husband and a father I'm daddy
Aqualad my boy
get us in an Aquaman trailer
she looks cool
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
okay
these sea films do have a look now huh
yeah every known species in the sea call
this place home
that doesn't mean they don't like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything
I'm gonna murder his family
burn his King his kingdom to Ash okay
we'll see about that oh the lost kingdom
heartbreak feels good in a place like
this
[Music]
imminent he's doing the chair pose
I know someone might go to help us
you look rough
good job little brother high five do not
call me brother
the Bromance you let this happen yeah
well I hate this job that's beautiful
bridges right
the king builds Bridges
he's still stronger than before
okay that's the black Trident
blacks time there were Seven Kingdoms
okay okay there's a curse upon them all
Lord of the Rings
he means
it's gonna be a cool fight at least one
king to rule them all
I don't know what I said but we can't
leave our children in a world without
hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
you leave the Seven Kingdoms will follow
mirror they shoulder ever hurt
let's just get clicks and people yelling
good SEO very nice
but they had her in a prison
filmed for Iron Man
hey create some Comics I've only read
two of them they're in the middle one
all right all right
okay killing it okay
I got thoughts you got thoughts who
doesn't have thoughts doesn't have
thoughts
yeah sure I got thoughts
um John Let's Hear John's thoughts first
you know I mean there's been so much
talk about this movie and about how
they've been pushing it back for like 10
straight years because every test
screening is hated it and just thinks
that DC should be burnt to the ground
and this is a trailer that sends me off
in two directions on the one hand I'm
like I can see how this could turn into
a kind of garish mess because this is a
bit of a cacophonous trailer however I
do really enjoy the idea of uh Arthur
and orm being thrust together on an
adventure after everything that happened
in the first movie I think that's a fun
hook and uh yeah I mean you know lest we
forget the first one made a billion
dollars and it was pretty dazzling in
terms of its World realization its
designs and all that stuff uh which
looks very fun and appealing here in a
post Avatar the way of water world I see
something like this and I just
immediately think what if James Cameron
but uh you know either I love a James
one joint and for as much of a you know
tumultuous and Rocky path to the theater
that this has had uh I still feel like
they could pull out something that is
really fun and enjoyable from this and I
mean this tone certainly feels a lot
more jovial a lot more humorous
um so I'm curious to know how people
will feel about that but it's not unlike
the first movie at the very least so uh
cautious optimism I guess we'll say
um and you know well wait to hear what
you guys think
koi
in a movie regarded as poorly as we've
heard I was expecting the trailer to be
worse uh I was a little concerned that
somehow a trailer would be boring now
yes you've got a two-hour movie it's
easy to grab three minutes of that look
great but this looks like the sequel to
the insanity that was Aquaman and I
think they know what to do as far as
like appealing to that demographic and
they've done that so if they've had this
extra time if they've done the scheduled
reshoots that they took those lessons I
mean there was a squid playing the drums
in the first one and this looks like you
know they're grabbing a seahorse jumping
out of the sea with a giant octopus
attached inside like they leaned in
instead of out this looks like a buddy
Bromance this looks like we're finally
getting some Black Manta story I
remember really like being really bummed
when the trench movie got canceled once
we heard it was a Black Manta movie so
I'm hoping some of the scripts from that
got incorporated into this so we can
actually see some of Yaya getting to be
as awesome as Yaya is and that's what
I'm looking forward to so all the checks
I wanted to hit the weirdness more Yaya
some romance like that's all here and
the visuals look like a lot of fun so in
an age of superhero fatigue seeing Momoa
open a trailer by grabbing green Spandex
and dive into this Insanity I think this
is a smart trailer
yes yes yes yes yes
um
I don't know there's to be totally
honest with you guys it's a good trailer
yeah I I like the trailer it's it's it's
fun it's wild it's whimsical and I agree
with everything you guys are saying in
the sense of how they are leaning more
into the things that seem like it worked
the last one it feels a lot more scopic
feels more adventurous and I'm looking
forward to that that budding
relationship of you know that that that
the action movie cliche sequel of like
oh now the villain they're gonna be
teaming up with in the second one like
you know like Thor love another love and
thunder throw the Dark World did yeah
you know and this is kind of like a
Trope and I like the everything about it
like yeah it looks it looks fun
um I'm not I I love Yaya I think he's
one of like our our best actors working
today
uh at the same time
just because like Black Manta in the
first movie
just wasn't all that threatening and it
seemed like kind of uh a thing they were
forcing into that film if I remember
that experience correctly it's been a
long time
I just I just remember that I was like
ah he's not that threatening to force
him in there he looks cool I should be
more excited about him but wasn't a big
fan ultimately of how he was serviced so
then for this trailer to be pitching him
as the main big Baddie I'm not that
excited for it well and it's a repeat
you know that's why yeah it's a repeat
Dynamic and weirdly I don't feel like
this trailer showed us anything that
felt that new comparison to the first
movie yeah or some new type of peril to
to really get me going like oh man this
is going to be one hell of a fight like
even the perilous and the villainous
stuff looks as fun and bouncy as it did
last time I will agree that as much
because I gave all those Paws of the
trailer this doesn't feel like I just
saw a trailer for the first time yeah
like watching this I was like
foreign
as much as they're trying to pitch us on
Stakes I didn't quite get a sense of of
of the stakes you know like it's
supposed to be fun and I like the the
beginning part of him being a dad I
think that's that's a fun little hook
and then also you know again the uh the
thing I'm looking forward to most is
probably going to be you know Jason
Momoa and Patrick Wilson interacting
whereas in the first movie it was him
and Amber Heard going on the Avengers
and now it's gonna be doing that here
with uh Patrick Wilson and maybe there's
gonna be some type of redemption Arc
underwater stuff yeah I mean it's like
visually this all looks cool I think I
think that is the thing like bringing up
Avatar the way of water
the first movie was more visually
impressive because that was pretty
Avatar the way of watching and now that
we have him should have released it on
time and now that we have the way of
water I'm like this looks really fun I
made it feels it has that like
it it looks kind of like those uh you
know an International Film you know what
I mean yeah which which is cool
but I guess the the the the Dazzle of it
is not hitting as strong yeah yeah yeah
I I'm rooting for it yeah that's gonna
happen I bet he's gonna use the the new
Trident and cut his hand off and we're
gonna get the hook Aquaman by the end
that's what I kept thinking I kept
thinking about he's gonna lose a hand
it's a sequel and he's gonna lose a hand
and it's gonna be at the handy eye to
build the stakes and then you get a hook
just like Thor's what I keep thinking
about because in the comics he's got a
hook handle on sweet can't wait for
options
it's coming there's that whole trailer
thinking about you they're gonna show me
around are they going to show us hook
hand they didn't but I think it's the
next trailer
um but
who knows I don't know I feel like they
kind of shot them at this I think this
movie's coming like way too late right
now which is weird because there's the
only one that made like a billion
dollars right yeah but it was like four
years ago five years ago I feel like
this got like black widow situation
where it's like well maybe you shouldn't
have waited this long and then with uh
honestly in the in the Italian age of
what's happening with DC and when that's
been communicated with the audience is
that like everything that's coming out
is probably like it's inconsequential
you probably don't really need to see it
yeah
um I don't feel like this trailer really
made the impact that maybe it needed to
as like this is something that you must
watch yeah I mean it just looks huge but
it also has the impact of like a
Saturday morning cartoon yeah this I
think this really needed to feel truly
special yeah and I'm like it looks fun
but that's kind of what a lot of us have
been saying about the other ones
it doesn't look bad but you know it well
I feel like it might have been smarter
to lead with the trailer that is a
little more Dynamic and has a little bit
more actual suspense or something like
that because here it just looks like
look how much effects we did yeah we've
had time to work on these effects yeah
and I mean James 1 is always a skilled
and gifted technician and you know can
glean good performances these guys Muse
here Patrick Wilson
um but you know I could absolutely see
how this movie could drop and just be
fine and I mean the original Aquaman is
sort of renowned for being like the
okayest DC EU movie that also happened
to make a billion dollars so I wonder
while I still expect this one out of you
know all the most recent DC EU remnants
to do pretty well just given its Legacy
I could also see a world in which it
still Falls well short of that Billy I'm
curious how it feels as far as the cut
by the time we get to it because I'm
curious with like the Ben Affleck of it
all with the reshoots with the I mean
the scheduled reshoots in addition to
perhaps the delay and like all those
things like is the movie gonna feel like
it's five movies like flash did where
flash felt like they had a bunch of
different cuts and then the studio cut
and then we got to see one will this
feel like that by the time we see it
yeah probably
just imagine it must 2023 what a year in
cinema these movies are made to be
modularly reworked so I can only imagine
them with as much time as it's been it's
gonna feel I just want to see the rage
face thumbnails on YouTube all day today
and people are like
it's coming oh yeah it's the greatest
show though like I honestly think that's
short of showing that off like the best
thing they could have done is have just
angry tweeters and she's in a little
jail or she's at least locked up
somewhere so it's a dog whistle for
everybody all righty well I give that
trailer
um it looks okay
[Music]
okay
I'll consider maybe watching it I will
watch it why not it's the last film in
the DC
uh guys what did you think about the
trailer
leave a like and
why don't we do a page for the day shout
out you know who I would love to see
underwater who who I would love to go
swimming with who's that in the deep
dark depths of the ocean that for sure
would have to be
undoubtedly
Chris whaml yes because Chris wamoff
swam off I feel like if there was
someone I could go scuba diving it would
be this guy he is known to be you know
one of those guys who just does
everything out of the kindness of his
heart he is willing to put his life at
risk in order to help others all the
time
and frankly it would be really fun to go
scuba diving with you and be like oh wow
look at that look at that mysterious
creature but I don't want to touch it
and then we send you in and oh my God
you get injured oh yeah okay and then he
gets he would have to get a hook hand
this is changing my bit oh no it's
changing my bit significantly you can
use it
do I go yes and or no butt I mean I'd go
yes I mean that hook hand is a no butt
for Chris you know what I mean he's got
a wipe with the other one for sure
okay what's wrong with it
and then he
he gets he swims to the surface and he
has to remove his they have to change
his hand down to give him a hook hand
yeah yeah and
well I think that's kind of the end of
it I mean yeah I mean also his name
sounds like an onomatopoeia from the
Silver age Comics like why I'm off like
I mean that's what happens when his hand
gets taken off Wham off oh okay look at
you comic book writer over here sanding
for you I was trying to help out I
should have slept I feel like
you know what right there this ending of
the trailer is just as captivating as
the trailer being perfectly fine
we love you
oh
[Music]